[Música]
hola bienvenidos a 5 minutos con hoy nos
acompaña el doctor carlos eduardo pérez
médico infectólogo de la universidad
nacional de colombia y asesor científico
de france 24 para hablar sobre la
tercera ola de la pandemia de kobe 19 en
américa latina' la región que más casos
diarios reporta según la organización
mundial de la salud doctor carlos
eduardo muy buenos días cuéntenos qué
papel han jugado las variantes del virus
en esta tercera ola las vacunas se están
funcionando contra ellas
definitivamente las nuevas variantes o
las variantes que conocemos están
expandiendo lo que está pasando en
brasil y los países vecinos explica ese
gran número de casos las vacunas si
protegen contra algunas de estas
variantes y son efectivas lo que pasa es
que también se corresponde con una baja
tasa de vacunación y al no tener una
cobertura gran de vacunación pues eso
permite que estas variantes que son
muchísimo más transmisibles estén
invadiendo más países y estén
contagiando a más personas
doctor en esta tercera ola son cada vez
más los jóvenes contagiados que llegan a
necesitar atención hospitalaria o
incluso cuidados intensivos por ejemplo
lo que está pasando en brasil que ahora
el 52 por ciento de la ocupación de las
ucis son de personas menores de 40 años
a qué se debe este fenómeno
son dos explicaciones grandes la primera
es definitivamente la variante es mucho
más transmisible es más efectivo el
contagio y las personas jóvenes son las
que tienen mayor movilidad en la
sociedad y por eso se contagian más y se
enferman más lo segundo es que los
grupos que están recibiendo la vacuna
son mayores de 80 años mayores de 70
años y en ellos se ha visto una
disminución del uso de los servicios
médicos entonces la mayor movilidad
entra mayor infección y no vacunación
mientras las personas vacunadas se están
enfermando menos y por eso explica ese
desplazamiento hacia la población joven
y hoy estamos viendo en brasil y en
otras regiones doctor después de dos
olas y miles de muertos la sociedad ha
aprendido a respetar las normas de
bioseguridad
definitivamente lo que vamos a meditar
es una vacuna o un tratamiento efectivo
porque el comportamiento humano no ha
modificado a pesar de haber pasado ya
por tres episodios en donde vemos que
las interacciones humanas son las
responsables del pico no hemos logrado a
poder hacer una disciplina social y en
algunos países pues sí lo han logrado
exitosamente por eso debemos enfocarnos
también a mantener nuestra disciplina
social pero aumentar las coberturas de
vacunación en nuestros países lo más
pronto posible doctor según los estudios
sobre la propagación del virus existe un
riesgo de contagio en actividades
fundamentales como por ejemplo ir al
trabajo o hacer mercado que en una
fiesta o en una multitud
lo que hemos visto paradójicamente es
que las personas no se contagian el
trabajo e incluso en actividades
curriculares son en actividades
extralaborales o extracurriculares donde
se ven la infección son las fiestas las
victorias uniones ahí es donde se hacen
los contagios por eso es importante
mantener la disciplina que se hace en el
trabajo igualmente en la casa
mantenernos alejados durante los fines
de semana
evitar las aglomeraciones evitar los
cumpleaños las celebraciones para evitar
la que haya mayor número de personas y
que las cepas puedan contagiar a más
personas doctor también hay una buena
noticia en circulación y es que las
mujeres embarazadas que se vacunan
pueden transmitir la inmunidad a su bebé
explíquenos cómo ocurre esto y qué
representa en términos científicos
estamos teniendo cada vez más datos
acerca de vacunaciones mujeres
embarazadas
primero es segura la vacunación entonces
no hay ninguna contraindicación para que
una mujer embarazada se pueda vacunar lo
segundo es que los anticuerpos es decir
las defensas pasan a su vez leyes como
si el bebé también se vacunará y es
efectiva la vacunación parece el novio o
padre e hijo es una buena noticia y muy
probablemente sea una conducta que todas
las mujeres embarazadas sobre todo en el
último trimestre también sean
priorizados para recibir la vacuna de
coke 19 es una buena noticia en medio de
todas estas funestas noticias de
contagios doctor rápidamente para
finalizar mientras porque los picos son
más altos mientras aumenta el número de
personas vacunadas
la vacunación todavía es insuficiente
nosotros estamos hasta ahora en una tasa
de vacunación de 135 o 10 por ciento de
la población y debe mantenerse la
desaceleración de casos con aumento de
la tasa de vacunación entonces qué pasa
que la gente se sigue aglomerando porque
la vacunación genera una confianza
innecesaria a la familia en las personas
y eso aumenta los casos doctor carlos
eduardo pérez muchas gracias por
acompañarnos en cinco minutos con
ustedes muchas gracias por sintonizarnos
quédense con nosotros
[Música]